[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 de vivir la guerra
civil a formar parte del primer equipo
olímpico de refugiados y participar en
los juegos de Río en 2016 Netflix
estrenó en su
plataformas la película que cuenta la
historia real de las hermanas yustra y
Sara mardini atletas que cruzaron Europa
en 2015 para refugiarse en Alemania un
peligroso el largo viaje en el que
tuvieron que nadar en el mar para
salvarse no solo ellas sino también a
otros refugiados de la fragira
embarcación con la cual llegaron a
Grecia además son actrices y hermanas
Las que interpretan a estas dos jóvenes
inspiradoras con actuaciones que están a
la altura de este desafío miramos el
trailer
[Música]
del lado de la plataforma movie pueden
descubrir o redescubrir otra historia
conmovedora Abrázame fuerte del actor y
director francés
la cinta Navegar entre realidad e
imaginación entre pasado presente y
futuro y retrata con complejidad y
delicadeza la separación y la pérdida de
sus seres queridos después del estreno
en las pantallas francesas el año pasado
a presentar su película en países del
mundo entero y nos contó lo mucho que la
persona a seguir discutiendo sobre su
obra con los periodistas y el público
cada persona ve algo diferente algunos
hablan de una película sobre la negación
otros de miedo de tener hijos de
imaginación de que se puede juzgar a un
personaje cuando no se sabe es decir al
principio podemos pensar Pero por qué
dejó a su marido Es fría Pero por qué
hace esto cuando otros por el contrario
medio celos llevo un año pensando en
dejarlo y no me atrevo
de hecho cada vez dice algo sobre el
mismo espectador En qué punto de su vida
se encuentra
[Música]
tras noticias culturales vamos a hablar
ahora de un libro que rinde homenaje a
la moda mexicana blanco pop una mirada
al estilismo de moda en México repasar
los 30 años de trayectoria de blanco pop
una de las agencias de estilismo de moda
más reconocida del país el dúo de
creativos o Juan de Dios Ramírez y
Alberto Escamilla querían ofrecer una
obra de colección para Los Amantes y
conocedores de la moda y el estilo la
actriz que hay del Castillo participó en
el lanzamiento del libro y destacó su
importancia la escuchamos Hemos llegado
donde Hemos llegado a donde sea que sea
este esto por el amor que tenemos a
nuestro trabajo y por la disciplina y
por la entrega y y ellos han entregado
toda su vida este libro son 30 años de
moda de México esto no existe no existe
esto así que esto es un legado que nos
dejan a México éramos Este programa con
los cuarenta años del mítico álbum
producido por Quincy Jones y publicado
el 30 de noviembre de 1982 el disco más
vendido de todos los tiempos tiene ahora
una revisión especial con 10 temas
inéditos algunos Son nuevos y los otros
son demos que son versiones de prueba de
canciones que el rey del pop tenía en
curso en la época
del lado de los estrenos musicales de la
semana la icónica onda estadounidense
metálica estrenó el tema looks eterno y
anunció el lanzamiento en abrir de 72
seasons que será el décimo segundo álbum
de su carrera y el primero desde 2016
[Música]
me toca el 50 y en la comisión de patio
de la cárcel el español Omar Montes
colabora por primera vez con el
arreguetonero puertorriqueño faruco
tomando parte de la letra del clásico
tema El patio de la choli
Nos despedimos con This is what I mean
de la rapero obra térmica Gracias a
ustedes por su confianza y sigan con
nosotros hay más cultura en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]